Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Bienvenue dans Septante Minutes Avec.
Cette semaine, mon invité est Christophe Marchand, avocat au barreau de Bruxelles, spécialisé en droit pénal international et qui compte parmi ses clients des noms comme Julian Assange de WikiLeaks, l'indépendantiste catalan Carles Puigdemont
et autrefois Edward Snowden. On
commence par remettre un petit peu les choses en contexte.
Quels sont les chefs d'accusation retenus contre Julian Assange ? Quel est le modus operandi de WikiLeaks
? Il nous raconte comment ses entretiens avec Julian Assange ont été enregistrés à leur insu
et nous explique pourquoi il a abandonné le dossier Snowden. Et puis cela étant fait,
on évolue petit à petit vers des questions plus globales, l'importance de WikiLeaks dans un contexte de surveillance de masse et d'impérialisme de la part des grandes puissances de notre monde.
Et on termine en discutant de la situation en Catalogne. Toutes mes excuses pour ce gros retard. L'épisode devait sortir à la base le 14 novembre.
On est aujourd'hui le 22. On évoque rapidement pendant l'entretien un dossier qui amène maître Marchand à prendre la défense d'une dissidente kazakhe.
L'actualité de cette affaire a fait qu'on a dû reporter notre entretien. Allez, on retrouve sans plus attendre Christophe Marchand.
C'est parti. Mon invité aujourd'hui est Christophe Marchand. Christophe Marchand, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter pour ceux qui ne vous connaissent peut-être pas ?
Donc, je m'appelle Christophe Marchand. Je suis avocat au Barreau de Bruxelles depuis une trentaine d'années et je travaille principalement en droit pénal, droit pénal international et les droits de l'homme, on va dire.
Alors, on peut de temps en temps lire votre nom dans la presse. Il y a quelques semaines, c'était dans le cadre de la défense de Botagoz Jilar-Demali.
Je ne sais pas si je prononce—
Très bien, très bien. Votre accent kazakhe est parfait.
Ok voilà, une opposante au régime, au régime kazakhe. Une autre fois, il s'agissait de la tentative d'attentat suicide contre la base militaire de Kleine Brogel qui—
L'accent flamand est bien aussi hein.
Qui abritait donc un détachement de l'armée américaine. Et bien sûr,
et c'est de ça dont on va beaucoup parler, je pense, pour les dossiers hautement controversés que sont, voilà, Julian Assange, Edward Snowden et l'indépendantiste catalan Carles Puigdemont.
Encore une fois, j'ai—
L'accent catalan qui est pas mal aussi. Vous avez beaucoup de cordes à votre arc.
Et donc voilà, on sent qu'il y a chez vous un certain attrait pour les dossiers sensibles, pour la controverse.
Est-ce que c'est juste de dire ça ? Est-ce que vous êtes d'accord ?
Donc je suis un peu malade hein, donc si jamais je tousse, ne m'en veuillez pas, ou si ma voix déraille.
Mais donc, je suis intéressé par la dissidence, en fait. C'est ça qui m'intéresse.
D'accord. Ah, intéressant.
C'est la dissidence. C'est ça qui m'intéresse dans le sens où je trouve que c'est vraiment à la base de notre société libérale, on va dire.
Le droit à la dissidence et le respect de la dissidence, c'est vraiment le fondement pour moi de la démocratie.
OK. Et d'où est-ce que ça vous vient ? Vous êtes un rebelle éternel ? Vous êtes...
Oh, pfff, je sais pas. Moi, j'ai été éduqué un peu comme ça. Je viens d'une famille libérale au sens politique du terme et—
Libre examen, libre penseur, etc. ?
Oui, ben, oui, la liberté personnelle. Quand j'ai dit à mon père, quand j'avais 15 ans, que j'étais communiste, il m'a—
D'accord.
...il m'a abonné aux Cahiers Marxistes pour me dire : « Si tu es communiste, lis ça mon fils ». Mais donc c'est un peu cette tradition-là, libérale, de, on a le droit de penser ce qu'on veut, mais il faut le faire convenablement.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a une exigence, je dirais intellectuelle et—
C'est ça. Vraiment libérale au sens philosophique du terme, pas au sens économique.
Non, ça peut aller avec, mais c'est pas obligatoire.
C'est ça, ouais. Ok, ok. J'évoquais il y a un instant donc votre liste de clients actuels. Comment c'est arrivé pour l'instant ?
Parce qu'on imagine que Julian Assange n'a pas pris son téléphone pour vous appeler depuis son ambassade.
Comment est-ce que vous avez mis le grappin sur de tels clients ?
Bah, en fait, le principe avec les avocats, c'est que les avocats sont consultés par des clients.
Donc c'est des clients qui viennent vous appeler, qui vous appellent. Donc, en effet, si Julian Assange m'a téléphoné directement de l'ambassade, il a fait téléphoner pour que je puisse rentrer dans son dossier.
Alors, comment ça se passe ? Ben c'est petit à petit, en fait. C'est vrai que moi, j'ai toujours rêvé de défendre des grandes causes, on va dire.
Déjà quand j'étais enfant, j'étais très choqué quand il y avait des injustices dans les classes et que, alors je me soulevais, je disais mon point de vue au professeur.
Et puis finalement, j'étais puni avec l'élève qui était injustement poursuivi. Enfin, c'est toujours quelque chose que j'ai eu chez moi, de défendre les autres.
Et donc c'était un vieux rêve, je crois, quand j'étais étudiant en droit, de devenir avocat de grande cause.
J'ai toujours rêvé de défendre Greenpeace. Ça, c'était un peu pour moi, je voulais défendre Greenpeace. Puis c'est arrivé un jour, donc j'ai réalisé mon rêve.
Je suis très content. Maintenant, c'est d'autres dossiers. C'est des dossiers Assange. C'est lié finalement à une activité qu'on a eue.
Je dis « on » parce qu'on est en équipe, en fait. Je suis pas tout seul. On est en équipe depuis plusieurs années, avec plusieurs personnes dont je reparlerai peut-être, mais—
Oui, d'ailleurs, vous, il y a plusieurs noms d'équipes sur lesquelles j'ai pu tomber. Il y a d'une part Jus Cogens, où nous sommes ici aujourd'hui.
Puis il y a un autre groupe que j'ai trouvé qui s'appelle Fair Trials.
Oui, c'est ça, oui.
Vous pouvez expliquer un petit peu ?
Il y a plusieurs— Bon, Jus Cogens, ça, c'est le nom de l'association d'avocats.
D'accord.
Donc, on est maintenant sept associés, je crois. On est une quinzaine d'avocats en tout. Et ça, c'est le nom de l'association d'avocats.
Et on a créé cette association il y a dix ans exactement. On a fêté les dix ans cette année,
avec une personne qui est un peu ma complice principale dans tout ça, qui est le professeur Anne Michaux, qui est professeure à l'ULB, ancienne vice-rectrice, elle était doyenne de la faculté.
Et avec Anne Michaux, on a vraiment développé, je dirais, une activité où on avait un souci de l'excellence intellectuelle, c'est-à-dire de vraiment
aller au pénal avec des arguments juridiques qui étaient très très clairs, très très précis au niveau scientifique, on va dire, de la science du droit,
et aussi un souci de développer les droits fondamentaux, les droits humains.
Et donc, on a créé alors différents,
différents contacts au fur et à mesure. On a créé des réseaux, on va dire, avec des ONG,
dont l'ONG que vous venez de citer, Fair Trials International, qui est une ONG qui est basée à Londres, mais qui a aussi une antenne à Bruxelles et à Washington,
et qui est une association très british fondée par des lords anglais qui ont pour objectif de faire triompher le procès équitable.
Donc c'est vraiment un financement purement privé
et on travaille avec eux. Il y a une autre ONG qui est importante aussi, qui est située à Berlin, qui s'appelle ECCHR, dont Anne Michaux, c'est administrateur et moi, je suis le référent en Belgique.
Oui. Vous évoquiez votre fierté d'avoir pu représenter Greenpeace.
Sur ce deuxième point que vous évoquiez, la question de faire avancer, voilà, la cause du droit humain, est-ce que vous auriez, par exemple, réussi à obtenir un précédent qui a eu un changement global qui dépasse
Christophe Marchand et qui a un impact plus général ?
Alors, un des— On a parlé de Jus Cogens, qui est l'association d'avocats. C'est un thème sur lequel on travaille beaucoup et qui nous anime, c'est la lutte contre la torture.
D'accord.
Donc la lutte contre la torture est un,
est un, comment dire, un motto au sein du cabinet. Donc, on a différents dossiers transversaux sur lesquels on travaille tous, qui sont souvent des dossiers pro bono, c'est-à-dire dans lesquels on n'est pas payés,
mais qui permettent de créer une espèce d'esprit de groupe où on se bat pour éviter que quelqu'un soit torturé ou pour sortir quelqu'un de la torture.
Et on le fait avec beaucoup d'ardeur et de concentration et on, comme je disais tout à l'heure, en cherchant l'excellence.
Et dans ce cadre-là, on a obtenu une jurisprudence à la Cour européenne des droits de l'Homme, sur cette lutte contre la torture à l'égard du Maroc.
C'est ce qu'on appelle la jurisprudence El-Aski, et
qui est une jurisprudence, en fait, qui a fait des petits en grande chambre,
qui a permis de— enfin, c'est pas en grande chambre, mais qui n'a pas fait l'objet d'un appel, donc ça équivaut à une décision en grande chambre, on va dire, puisque l'appel a été rejeté.
Voilà, une petite question technique vite faite. Mais qui a,
je dirais, établi le fait que, en Europe, on ne peut pas utiliser dans un procès pénal comme preuve des informations dont on pense qu'elles auraient pu être obtenues sur la torture dans un État tiers à l'Europe.
Et donc là, ça concernait le Maroc, mais il y a des décisions aussi qui concernent maintenant la Jordanie ou qui concernent d'autres États.
Si demain, par exemple, il y a des—
ou qui peuvent concerner les preuves qui ont été recueillies à Guantanamo, mais si, par exemple, il y a la torture demain, je sais pas, au Kazakhstan, parce que c'est un pays dans lequel il y a de la torture de manière systématique,
eh bien, les auditions de personnes du Kazakhstan ne peuvent pas être utilisées comme preuve.
Ce qui était— En Belgique. Ce qui n'était pas le cas avant cet arrêt El-Aski, qui date de septembre 2012, je crois.
OK. Donc effectivement, là, on est en plein dans le—
La création de précédent, oui.
Oui, la création de précédent et les avancements de droits humains que vous évoquiez, effectivement. Donc là, c'est effectivement très parlant.
Pour revenir donc au cas, voilà, qu'on a cité, hein, je donnais les noms de Edward Snowden, Julian Assange et Carles Puigdemont.
Concrètement, qu'est-ce que vous faites pour eux ? Est-ce que vous êtes leur représentant au niveau local, au niveau de la Belgique, au niveau européen ?
Est-ce que vous travaillez avec eux en ce qui concerne leur déboire au niveau américain ou...
Ça dépend des dossiers. Donc avec— Dans le dossier Snowden, je ne travaille plus.
Oui.
Parce que donc j'étais dans l'équipe de Snowden. Et puis l'avocat américain qui est Ben Wizner, qui est le chef de l'équipe de Snowden, m'a dit : « Écoute, tu dois choisir entre Snowden et Assange, parce que tu peux pas défendre les deux ».
OK.
Parce qu'il pourrait y avoir un conflit d'intérêt.
Pour une question d'image, pour une question de conflit d'intérêt.
Conflit d'intérêt, éventuellement, ils peuvent être poursuivis tous les deux ensemble. Donc, il m'a dit : « C'est mieux ».
Moi, je crois personnellement que c'est une question d'image. Il a toujours été très, très, euh, Ben, très, comment dire ?
Ça a toujours été très important pour lui de séparer Snowden d'Assange, parce que Snowden, c'est un peu l'ange et Assange, le démon, on va dire, je trouve, simplement.
Vous avez dit Ben, c'est ça ?
Oui, Ben Wizner, l'avocat de Snowden.
OK.
Qui est un avocat new-yorkais, qui est un ami. Et Assange, lui, il est plus, je dirais, vu comme un démon.
C'est ça.
C'est un peu l'ange et le démon. Donc, j'ai choisi le démon.
Voilà. On va revenir justement sur ce choix qui est très intéressant, mais c'est vrai que quand on fait des micro-trottoirs aux États-Unis et qu'on pose des questions sur Edward Snowden,
il y a une confusion générale et on dit : « Ah oui, Edward Snowden, le monsieur de WikiLeaks qui a envoyé les vidéos en Irak, etc.
» Donc, il y a une espèce de confusion générale. Donc, je comprends à la limite que son avocat essaye un petit peu de—
De séparer.
Bien séparer les deux parce que je crois que, comme vous disiez, le démon et toute la—
C'est la démonisation d'Assange. Il a été démonisé, on va dire.
D'accord.
C'est un peu ça le— Ça, c'est mon point de vue, mon point de vue est celui-là. Il a fait l'objet d'une mise en scène pour qu'il devienne exécrable.
Bon alors, c'est quelqu'un qui est controversé, hein, ça, on y reviendra. Mais je pense que— Et d'ailleurs, dans le dernier rapport du rapporteur spécial,
ou plutôt du communiqué de presse du rapporteur spécial contre la torture,
il indiquait clairement qu'il considérait qu'il faisait l'objet d'une persécution afin d'être noirci par les États américains et que ça équivalait à de la torture.
Donc, il y a, depuis très longtemps, une stratégie de la part des États-Unis de noircir—
D'accord.
...je n'aime pas le mot, Assange.
Mais alors, comment est-ce qu'on explique que ce ne soit pas autant le cas ou même pas du tout le cas avec quelqu'un comme Edward Snowden ou quelqu'un comme Chelsea Manning ?
Alors, je pense que la raison, c'est qu'elle se trouve dans le discours que Mike Pompeo a fait quand il a accédé, quand il est devenu chef de la CIA.
C'était il y a deux ans, je crois, avant qu'il soit maintenant ministre de Trump. Et il a fait un discours pour dire que c'était quoi, ça allait être quoi son programme.
Et le premier point, alors qu'on était en plein au moment de l'État islamique, où l'État islamique était en pleine expansion et que ça devait être lui, l'ennemi, je dirais, des États-Unis.
Il a dit : « Le plus grand ennemi des États-Unis et ce qui va déterminer mon mandat comme chef de la CIA, c'est abattre WikiLeaks, abattre Assange. »
Mh.
Le numéro un, c'était Assange. Pourquoi ? Et il a défini. Alors, il a dit : « Oui, parce qu'Assange est un service secret, informal, non-state, secret service.
» Donc non étatique, donc un agent d'information, de renseignement informel, non étatique, mais hostile, hostile.
Ça, c'était le mot clé. Hein, donc c'est comme si WikiLeaks était une agence de renseignement non étatique, hostile aux États-Unis.
Ok, mais on peut déconstruire ça ? Qu'est-ce que... Pour les néophytes, en quoi est-ce que ça n'est pas vrai de dire ça ?
Puisqu'il y a effectivement la notion de fuite, la notion d'information confidentielle, secrète, qui sont récupérées par cette entité, WikiLeaks, qui est effectivement non étatique.
Donc, si je reprends point par point les éléments, vous n'avez pas l'air d'accord avec Mike Pompeo à ce sujet-là.
Non, ben je pense pas que c'est le seul point de désaccord que j'ai avec lui.
Oui.
Mais celui-là, en tout cas, mais il s'en fout d'ailleurs. Mais le point de désaccord sur cette qualification, c'est de qu'est-ce que c'est WikiLeaks.
Mh.
Et c'est ça la définition qu'il faut chercher. C'est quoi WikiLeaks ? Qu'est-ce qu'Assange a inventé ? C'est ça la question.
Et Assange a inventé, à l'ère de l'Internet, la création d'une plateforme Internet, WikiLeaks, sur laquelle des gens peuvent déposer des informations de manière confidentielle et cryptée qui ne permettent pas d'identifier la source.
C'est le système du whistleblowing, c'est le système des lanceurs d'alerte qui a été créé par Assange et qui est créé par WikiLeaks.
Mh.
Et lorsqu'on dit à— je suis pas d'accord avec Pompeo quand il dit que c'est une agence de renseignement non étatique, peut-être.
Ça, je dis OK, mais agence de renseignement hostile, non. C'est une agence de renseignement, c'est un publisher, comme on dit en anglais, c'est quelqu'un qui publie des informations. Donc c'est—
Couvert par le premier amendement etc.
Ce n'est pas une agence de renseignement, il recherche pas des informations. Il n'y a pas d'agents qui vont aller chercher des informations.
Il y a quand même tout de même la notion de, donc Chelsea Manning, au moment où elle était encore employée dans l'armée américaine.
Ouais.
Il y a ce fameux point, il est accusé pour l'instant d'avoir proposé son aide à Chelsea Manning pour pirater un ordinateur.
Oui, c'est faux. Nous, on dit que c'est la propagande américaine par rapport à-
Vous reniez complètement le-
Non, c'est faux. Au niveau des faits, c'est faux. Qu'est-ce que Assange a juste fait ? Il lui a expliqué comment changer son mot de passe. C'est juste ça.
Mh.
Mais elle avait déjà un mot de passe et un accès. On parle de hacking. Ça veut dire quoi, hacking ? C'est de l'intromission illicite dans un système informatique.
L'information que moi, j'ai entendue, c'est qu'il y avait l'idée qu'elle récupère le hash d'un mot de passe et que Julian Assange ait proposé, ce qui est très dur,
extrêmement difficile, de partir du hash pour récupérer le vrai mot de passe.
Je crois que ça va faire l'objet d'un débat judiciaire, mais en tout cas, c'est tout à fait contesté que ce soit ça.
D'accord.
Ça, c'est la première accusation. Et puis la deuxième accusation, qui est, elle, purement basée sur cette définition de Mike Pompeo, c'est-à-dire de dire que WikiLeaks,
le fait d'avoir inventé cette plateforme où les gens peuvent mettre des informations de manière confidentielle et cryptée, que ça atteint la sécurité des États-Unis.
Ça, c'est vraiment l'accusation principale, parce que finalement, ce système WikiLeaks a été reproduit par plein de médias.
Sur Mediapart, vous trouvez un site dans lequel vous pouvez déposer ces informations.
Oui, oui, tout à fait.
Tous les médias du monde ont reproduit ce que Assange a inventé. C'est pour ça que je dis toujours que-
La notion de whistleblowing, effectivement, est partie de là, oui.
Oui, c'est ça. Et vous pouvez pas avoir de whistleblowing si vous avez pas le whistle. Il faut un sifflet pour siffler les informations.
Et ce sifflet, c'est ça qu'il a inventé.
Cela dit, la grande différence, c'est que si on soumet son information à un journal comme La Libre, un journal comme Mediapart ou autre,
il y a à ce moment-là des journalistes qui récupèrent cette information et qui peuvent servir de juges, de savoir : OK, qu'est-ce qu'on publie ?
Est-ce qu'on va publier des informations qui mettent en danger des agents américains situés en zone de combat ? Il n'y a pas de filtre sur WikiLeaks.
Tout est balancé. Et si vous êtes agent américain ou agent secret pour n'importe quel État-nation,
et que vous êtes en zone de combat et que vous êtes en danger et que votre nom est tout d'un coup publié sur WikiLeaks,
là, il y a une certaine notion de mise en danger, une certaine, on pourrait dire, d'hostilité.
Ça n'est jamais arrivé.
Ça n'est jamais arrivé ?
OK.
Et si c'était arrivé, il serait poursuivi pour ça aujourd'hui.
Mh.
Donc il est poursuivi pour un risque théorique, en fait. C'est ça qui est un peu particulier. C'est de dire qu'en fait, les informations qu'il divulgue sont de nature à créer un danger.
Mais il n'y a aucun élément, il n'y a aucun dossier concret où Assange serait poursuivi pour un assassinat d'une personne ou...
Il n'y a rien. En tout cas, moi, j'en ai pas connaissance. Qu'on nous les présente à nous, la défense.
Il y a eu le cas du viol qui est intéressant à développer.
Ah oui, oui. Non, mais ça n'a rien à voir avec WikiLeaks, ça.
Mais vous disiez Julian Assange n'a jamais été, voilà, accusé d'un meurtre.
L'affaire du viol, c'est-
D'un personnel, oui.
...c'est une cabale, ça. Donc c'est une cabale contre lui, c'est-à-dire une accusation qui est faite de ce qu'il aurait violé.
Enfin, on peut parler de cette affaire suédoise un instant, mais c'est quoi cette affaire suédoise ? C'est qu'il a des relations avec deux femmes en Suède
et qu'à un moment donné, elles se rendent compte qu'elles ont toutes les deux une relation au même moment avec lui.
Et donc elles vont à la police pour dire : « Est-ce que c'est possible de lui faire passer un test sida parce qu'on a eu des relations sexuelles non protégées avec lui ?
» C'est ça la base. Et le policier leur dit : « Mais vous savez, avoir des relations sexuelles non protégées, c'est un viol en droit suédois. » À partir de là-
La notion de viol est effectivement très différente en Suède.
Oui. À partir de là, alors, il y a le dossier qui se monte, il est classé une première fois sans suite immédiatement par le procureur qui reçoit le dossier qui dit : « Mais il n'y a pas d'infraction.
» Et puis il est rouvert après par un autre procureur, puis il sera reclassé sans suite trois ans après. Et maintenant, il vient de le rouvrir bien opportunément au moment où il est arrêté.
Franchement, qu'on arrête de rigoler avec cette histoire d'affaire suédoise. Je sais pas si vous avez vu, il va y avoir une conférence de presse maintenant du procureur suédois le 19 novembre qui va donner des informations sur le cas.
Mais l'actualité du dossier suédois, elle suit en fait l'actualité du dossier américain. Donc moi, à un moment donné, je me dis : « Mais c'est quand même pas possible.
» Et donc on a découvert qu'il y avait eu des échanges de mails entre le procureur suédois et la police américaine.
Et la police américaine, ça n'a rien à voir avec le dossier de viol. Mais on a voulu avoir le contenu de ces mails et le procureur suédois dit : « Ah ben, je les ai effacés, désolé, je les ai plus.
» Donc on n'a jamais su exactement de quoi ils ont parlé, mais écoutez, cette histoire suédoise, c'est too much.
Alors moi, je veux dire, pour la poursuite de toutes les infractions, surtout les infractions d'agression sexuelle à l'égard des femmes.
Pour moi, c'est quelque chose qui est très important pour moi et on a des dossiers, on travaille de source dans les dossiers là-dessus. Donc c'est pas,
et là, vous parliez d'Achille, de Schiefmund. On a eu une décision de la Cour européenne des droits de l'homme aussi dans cette matière-là récemment, qui a constaté qu'en Belgique, et ce qu'on disait depuis très longtemps,
les femmes qui déposaient plainte pour viol ou agression sexuelle étaient très mal reçues par la police, à un point tel qu'elles avaient peur finalement de déposer ce type de plainte.
Et la Cour européenne des droits de l'homme a avalisé ce point de vue-là dans un dossier et a condamné la Belgique pour ça.
C'est un dossier qu'on a mené il y a deux, trois ans. Donc c'est un sujet qui pour moi m'est très important. Et donc malheureusement,
je suis pas adepte du tout de la théorie du complot et des trucs, mais je dois constater qu'il y a des éléments objectifs qui me font penser
que cette affaire suédoise, elle est manipulée, elle est utilisée, elle est instrumentalisée, pour nuire
à Assange, dans le cadre de l'autre affaire qui est l'affaire principale, qui est l'affaire du mandat d'arrêt américain.
Oui. C'est évidemment très compliqué dans ma position, puisqu'on a d'une part, voilà, ces accusations, je disais, la notion de tentative de piratage, la notion de tentative de viol, etc.
Toutes ces choses qui sont affichées, voilà, reprises régulièrement dans la presse. Et vous me dites aujourd'hui : « Ah, toutes ces choses-là sont absolument inventées, instrumentalisées.
» Voilà, une grande part de fiction dans ces éléments-là. Voilà, je ne vais pas prendre parti. On a bien compris aujourd'hui votre point de vue.
Je veux dire, Assange, c'est un prisonnier politique.
C'est vraiment quelqu'un qui est en prison parce qu'il a mis sur pied un système de
réception d'informations pour dénoncer les plus graves violations des droits fondamentaux qui ont été réalisées au XXIe siècle par les États-Unis d'Amérique.
On parle ici des war logs, on parle des-- donc c'est pour ça qu'il est poursuivi.
Mais donc j'aimerais revenir sur cette notion. Vous dites, Snowden et Assange, anges et démons. Et vous dites : « Démonisation, c'est un construit, c'est artificiel, etc.
» Qu'est-ce qui fait que Mike Pompeo n'est pas monté au Sénat pour dire, enfin au Congrès plutôt : « Snowden est l'ennemi public, il a révélé, etc. » ?
Oui, oui, non mais Assange, il a créé le système. Il a créé WikiLeaks, il a inventé WikiLeaks qui a été reproduit par tout le monde.
Pour moi, d'une certaine manière,
il a un côté un peu génial parce qu'il a toujours une vision un peu d'avance sur la société et sur cette société
du XXIe siècle, société électronique, de savoir quelle influence, finalement, là, j'arrive au cœur de la question par rapport à Assange,
c'est de savoir, on est maintenant face à une révolution, la révolution numérique, quelque chose d'invraisemblable,
que ce soit par rapport au stockage des données, par rapport à la manière dont les données circulent.
Hein, c'est loin, la presse de Gutenberg, c'est terminé. Le document papier, c'est plus comme ça qu'on communique.
Maintenant, on communique différemment, on communique électroniquement. Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ? Ben ça veut dire qu'il y a tous des procédés techniques qui sont mis en œuvre.
Par exemple, quand on diffuse un podcast comme celui-ci, ben ça passe par Internet, ça passe par des fils, ça passe par l'éther.
Et toutes ces informations-là, elles peuvent être récupérées et elles sont collectées. Ça, c'est la révélation Snowden, c'est le collect it all.
Ça veut dire il faut tout collecter. Ça veut dire que l'entièreté, on l'oublie parfois, mais c'est quand même invraisemblable, l'entièreté de la vie électronique du monde est collectée par les États-Unis qui récupèrent toutes les informations.
Le data center en Utah qui font quatre point cinq pétaoctets ou je ne sais plus.
Ah, des pétaoctets maintenant.
Oui, oui, voilà, c'est des trucs absolument... voilà.
Donc tout est récolté là. C'est ça la société d'aujourd'hui, qu'on n'a jamais connu que l'État ait un contrôle aussi étendu, approfondi sur la vie des gens.
Parce que moi, mon smartphone, parce que c'est ça qu'on récupère, c'est tout mon smartphone. Qu'est-ce que j'ai dans mon smartphone ?
J'ai mes rendez-vous, j'ai mes déplacements, j'ai avec qui je mange, j'ai avec qui je fais du sport, j'ai avec qui je suis en relation professionnelle, mais aussi familiale.
J'ai tous mes WhatsApp avec mes groupes de famille, on s'échange des photos rigolotes. Tout ça, tout ça, tout ça, toute ma vie privée complète et professionnelle est récupérée.
Alors, par rapport à cette intrusion gigantesque dans la vie des gens,
au XXIe siècle, qui est due à cette révolution Internet, qui est assez positive, hein, c'est que c'est vraiment un progrès, on va dire, gigantesque dans l'histoire de l'humanité.
Comment est-ce qu'on va réagir, nous, en tant que citoyens, par rapport à ce pouvoir exponentiel gigantesque de l'État dans l'intrusion dans notre vie privée ?
La réponse, c'est Assange qui la donne, c'est WikiLeaks.
Mh.
C'est-à-dire
la recherche de la transparence. Il faut de la transparence. Il faut aller chercher la transparence dans des leaks diplomatiques,
dans des leaks relatives à des affaires judiciaires, dans des leaks qui sont relatives à des affaires commerciales, privées, comment les sociétés commerciales
agissent, dans des leaks qui sont relatives à des événements qui sont graves, qui sont cachés, parce qu'on veut pas les voir et que l'État enlève du système.
Je donne des exemples. Et c'est un peu particulier par rapport à WikiLeaks. Moi, cette idée de WikiLeaks, c'est quoi ?
C'est que-- Et qui n'a pas été facile pour moi de comprendre et finalement de dire pourquoi pas. C'est quoi ?
C'est une banque de données qui contient-- C'est une espèce de boîte noire de l'humanité, on va dire, et qui contient plein d'informations authentiques.
C'est le seul critère.
Oui, mais c'est la grande différence. Voilà, on parlait de ce combat pour la transparence.
Oui.
Snowden, Assange, même combat, mais les méthodes sont différentes.
Et donc je reviens avec cette différence qui est
soumettre l'information à des journalistes qui vont filtrer l'information ou bien mettre en place une plateforme WikiLeaks où le whistleblower qui, voilà, qui s'invente whistleblower,
le lanceur d'alerte, publie
et personne n'est là pour filtrer, personne n'est là pour-
Il y a un filtre à WikiLeaks, hein, c'est pas juste dire qu'il y a pas de filtre. Il y a un filtre, le seul filtre.
Donc quand vous envoyez une information à WikiLeaks et quand il était dans l'ambassade, parfois Julian me téléphonait pour demander de vérifier des choses parce qu'il voulait savoir, il voulait même attendre avant de publier des choses.
Le filtre qui est fait à WikiLeaks, le contrôle qui est fait avec WikiLeaks, c'est de savoir est-ce que l'information est originale ?
Est-ce qu'elle est vraie ? Est-ce que la source est vraie et originale ? C'est-à-dire, est-ce que c'est un document original.
Par exemple, pour donner vraiment des exemples qui sont choquants, hein.
Par exemple, dans WikiLeaks, vous avez tout le dossier judiciaire Dutroux, hein, avec notamment les rapports d'expertises médico-légaux qui concernent les petites qui ont été assassinées et violées.
Donc, vous imaginez l'horreur que ça contient. D'autre part, si c'était mes enfants, moi, je trouverais ça hyper choquant.
C'est sûr, oui.
C'est une atteinte à la vie privée de ces personnes, des victimes, mais aussi de leur famille qui est énorme, qui est gigantesque, qui est inacceptable pour ces personnes-là.
Mais néanmoins, à WikiLeaks, quelqu'un, je sais pas qui, leur a envoyé le dossier.
Ils ont analysé pour voir si le dossier était bien le vrai dossier et ils l'ont mis dans les banques de données de WikiLeaks parce qu'ils trouvaient que ça avait un intérêt, que ce dossier Dutroux, qui a tellement défrayé la chronique
dans les années 90,
ben, soit à disposition pour que les citoyens, au nom de la transparence, puissent avoir accès et se refaire leur propre religion par rapport à ce dossier-là, par exemple.
Même chose par rapport aux attentats de Nice,
hein. Attentat de Nice, vous vous souvenez peut-être les photos ou les images terrifiantes de ce camion qui déboule de nulle part et qui fauche les gens comme ça dans un accès de barbarie gigantesque.
Ces images ont été retirées du Net. C'est-à-dire que les médias ont décidé, les journaux, avec raison sans doute, de ne pas les diffuser.
Mais ces images se retrouvent sur WikiLeaks parce qu'ils considèrent que ça a un intérêt dans l'histoire
de l'humanité ou l'histoire des hommes, en tout cas ce jour-là, que ce soit accessible, qu'on n'oublie pas les horreurs dont nous sommes capables.
C'est aussi pour ça que WikiLeaks-
Il y a aussi là, d'une autre façon, sous un autre aspect, aussi une philosophie de collect it all chez WikiLeaks, c'est-à-dire toute l'information-
D'intérêt général, d'intérêt public. Tout à fait. Tout à fait.
...les vidéos des attentats, les rapports dans l'affaire Dutroux, etc.
Oui. Démarche historienne, tout à fait.
On collecte tout, voilà, dans une démarche, voilà-
Mais c'est pas collecter tout, hein, c'est collecter-- 'Fin, ils ont pas accès, ils vont pas pirater.
Non, non.
C'est pas du piratage, c'est les gens déposent. Les gens viennent apporter les infos.
OK, donc peut-être pas collect it all, mais display it all.
Conserve it all, je sais pas comment on dit en anglais pour le conserver, mais si ça a un intérêt public, hein, si ça a un intérêt pour l'ensemble de la population, voilà.
Vous parlez d'un filtre qui était le filtre de la vérité.
Oui.
Maintenant, vous évoquez une deuxième condition.
Parce qu'il y a un intérêt public. Et donc vous dites chaque document est reviewed, est inspecté pour cette notion d'intérêt public.
Qui est très large, hein. Nous, on a déjà eu des discussions. À un moment donné, quand ça s'est su que je défendais Assange, j'ai reçu des emails de personnes qui me disaient que des informations qu'ils avaient,
qui touchaient à leur vie privée, se trouvaient dans WikiLeaks et qui souhaitaient qu'elles soient enlevées.
Et alors donc du coup-- Mais donc on a eu des discussions avec plusieurs avocats au sein de WikiLeaks pour savoir oui, mais est-ce qu'on mettrait pas une limite, par exemple, liée à la vie privée ?
Hein. Et moi, j'étais plutôt défendeur de cette position-là, mais j'ai perdu. Les autres disaient non, il faut pas. Il faut que ce soit un intérêt public au sens large, même si ça a une atteinte à la vie privée.
Je pense l'exemple le plus dur pour nous en tant que Belges, parce que c'est quelque chose qui nous touche profondément, c'est l'affaire Dutroux.
De savoir que, voilà, ce dossier est disponible sur WikiLeaks,
ça montre le côté controversé de WikiLeaks aussi. C'est-à-dire qu'on peut ne pas être d'accord avec cette position, de dire : « Mais finalement, vous avez décidé de donner un accès à plein d'informations
en violation de la vie privée dans l'affaire Dutroux ou dans d'autres cas, en violant d'autres droits.
Nous ne sommes pas d'accord. » Mais la réponse est si. C'est ça le prix de la transparence.
C'est ça le prix de la montée en puissance des États modernes qui ont tellement de pouvoir sur nos vies, qui savent tellement tout de notre vie, que nous devons être en capacité de pouvoir
montrer l'activité de l'État, sans avoir égard à la vie privée.
Oui. C'est là toute la difficulté avec ce dossier. C'est effectivement, on met dans la balance, d'une part, la notion d'intérêt public et d'autre part, la notion de sécurité, de vie privée, ces choses-là.
Je ne suis pas sûr qu'on arrivera à résoudre cette question aujourd'hui. Donc pour revenir un petit peu sur le rôle—
La question, c'est vraiment : est-ce que c'est pénalement répréhensible ? Est-ce qu'Assange doit aller en prison pour ça ?
Oui, ça, c'est vrai.
La réponse est non. Évidemment, non. C'est juste quelqu'un qui exerce sa liberté d'expression.
Oui, et alors, il y a aussi cette notion de— Donc pour l'instant, il est dans un centre de haute sécurité à Londres.
Oui.
Il y a un jugement qui va être rendu pour finaliser, pour approuver, pour valider la demande d'extradition vers les États-Unis.
Finalement, si vous êtes convaincu du bien-fondé de son action, du fait que ça n'est pas pénalement répréhensible, qu'il est blanc comme neige, finalement—
Je dis pas ça hein, mais je dis que c'est pas pénalement répréhensible.
Voilà.
Il y a une diff— On peut le condamner moralement.
Oui, oui, ça.
Si vous voulez. Là, c'est votre liberté individuelle. Vous pouvez le condamner moralement. Mais le condamner pénalement, le mettre en prison et le torturer, parce que c'est ça qu'ils font, le Royaume-Uni, c'est une honte complète.
C'est une honte complète. Il y a aucune raison de le mettre dans un centre. Moi, je l'ai vu plusieurs fois, les semaines précédentes, là, à Londres, c'est terrifiant.
C'est vraiment une prison, j'ai jamais vu ça. Et il a accès à personne. Il voit 23 heures sur 24, il est tout seul dans sa cellule avec une caméra sur lui.
C'est invraisemblable qu'il subisse ce traitement-là alors qu'il a juste publié des informations.
Hm. Il a publié des informations, c'est ça qu'il a fait, qui sont des atteintes à la sécurité nationale des États-Unis, certes, mais qui montrent quoi ?
Qui montrent des crimes de guerre. Vous vous souvenez le truc, c'est les Warlocks. C'est des militaires qui sont avec des joysticks comme si c'était un jeu vidéo, qui tuent des gens, des journalistes. C'est ça.
Mmh.
C'est un truc invraisemblable. Et c'est pour ça qu'il est poursuivi. C'est pour ça qu'il est en prison. C'est pour ça qu'il est torturé.
C'est inacceptable au 21e siècle en Europe. C'est inacceptable.
Mais donc finalement, si votre conviction, c'est que ça n'est pas pénalement répréhensible,
pourquoi ne pas dire : « Bah OK, on accepte alors la demande d'extradition vers les États-Unis et on attend qu'il se fasse juger et nous sommes convaincus du bienfait de...
» Ce qui est très naïf hein, je fais un petit peu l'avocat du diable, mais—
Non, non, pas du tout. C'est la confiance qu'on doit avoir dans les États-Unis. Moi, je trouve que normalement, les États-Unis est un grand État,
dans lequel nous, on a une histoire longue et constructive et fructueuse à plein d'égards,
y compris sur le développement des droits fondamentaux.
Mais là... Donc a priori, c'est la confiance qui règne entre les États-Unis et l'Europe. Mais là, sur ce dossier de whistleblowing, et des lanceurs d'alerte, pas du tout.
Là, les États-Unis sont en pleine dérive. Ils sont en pleine dérive. Moi, mes amis avocats américains me disaient : « Mais non, tu vas voir, il va jamais y avoir de mandat d'arrêt contre Assange.
» Je dis : « Bah OK. » « C'est impossible, c'est contraire à l'amendement je sais plus quoi de la Constitution américaine,
c'est la protection, c'est la liberté individuelle, liberté d'expression, c'est sacré chez nous, encore plus que chez vous en Europe.
» Et puis paf, on voit qu'il y a un mandat d'arrêt où il risque 175 ans de prison. Donc ça veut dire que là-bas, aux États-Unis, au niveau de la communauté juridique, ils sont très mal à l'aise.
Ils se rendent compte que finalement, il y a des dérives qui sont importantes.
Mmh.
Et puis quand on voit comment Chelsea Manning a été traitée.
A été remise en prison—
Elle est toujours en prison là hein.
Elle est toujours en prison, ouais.
Toujours en prison hein. Parce qu'elle refuse de parler à propos de Julian Assange. Donc c'est vraiment une espèce de mesure de rétorsion.
C'est incroyable. Elle est de nouveau en prison. Mais déjà, tout son procès était déjà particulier puisqu'elle était condamnée à 35 ans de prison pour ses révélations qui révélaient des crimes de guerre.
Donc c'est quelque chose qui, dans les discussions juridiques, il y a un grand principe toujours, oui, on est tenu à certains principes.
Par exemple, pour dire les choses très simplement, si je me fais agresser et que ma vie est en jeu, je peux, par force majeure, on va dire, me défendre et rendre des coups.
Et la force majeure est un élément important, justement, qui permet à un moment donné de faire une balance des intérêts.
Quand Chelsea Manning donne des informations sur des crimes de guerre, elle va violer son secret. Elle va violer ce qui est sans doute très important pour elle en tant que militaire, c'est son attachement à sa hiérarchie militaire.
Elle le fait pourquoi ? Par force majeure. Elle est obligée de le faire parce qu'il faut révéler ça. On peut pas laisser l'État continuer à cacher ces crimes de guerre parce qu'il y a jamais de justice.
Il y a jamais de justice si c'est pas révélé à un moment donné. Et donc ça, c'est nécessaire à un moment donné que l'État, on puisse le mettre en face de ses responsabilités.
Et puis, moi, je vois toujours les choses en plusieurs phases. Quand on attaque un État, d'abord, la première phase, c'est l'analyse.
La deuxième phase, c'est prendre les mesures provisoires pour empêcher que la violation des droits fondamentaux continue.
Et la troisième phase, qui est la plus importante, c'est la responsabilité des personnes impliquées là-dedans.
Pour en revenir au rôle qui est le vôtre, le rôle d'avocat.
Oui.
Défendre ce qui est finalement un ennemi de la Maison-Blanche hein, puisqu'on a entendu régulièrement les déclarations de Donald Trump au sujet de Julian Assange, ou même un ennemi de l'État américain.
Quelles conséquences est-ce que ça a pour l'avocat que vous êtes ? Est-ce que vous vous sentez doublement surveillé ?
Est-ce que vous vous sentez—
Bah, je sais pas. Par rapport à la surveillance—
Épuré ?
...oui non, ma surveillance, je sais pas comment elle est. Je connais pas l'étendue de la surveillance dont je fais l'objet des services de renseignement.
Mmh-mmh.
Bon. Il y a plusieurs services de renseignement qui sont sans doute très intéressés par ce que je fais. D'abord, il y a le dossier kazakh, il y a le dossier des Catalans, il y a le dossier du président Correa que je défends aussi.
Donc j'imagine que les services équatoriens sont aussi intéressés. Il y a beaucoup de dossiers qui touchent finalement à la sécurité de l'État de certains pays.
Donc voilà, j'imagine qu'il y a plein de services qui sont intéressés par ce qu'on fait. Mais donc moi, mon point de vue, c'est je le sens pas, je le vois pas.
Oui, oui, mon ordinateur est hacké, ça, c'est sûr. Et je dis parfois même, j'essaie de, quand je suis dans des
dossiers un peu sensibles et puis j'essaye avec ma souris de faire des actions, je vois que ma souris va de l'autre côté.
Et je sais que quelque part, il y a un type qui s'amuse avec ma souris. Et ça m'amuse parce qu'alors, ce que je fais, je travaille offline ou—
C'est ça.
Parce que c'est quelque chose qui est difficile, parfois, de travailler.
Donc vous prenez des mesures à ce niveau-là en termes de chiffrement, en termes d'échanges avec vos clients ?
Oui, c'est ça. Oui, je travaille pas mal en PGP, je travaille beaucoup avec des messageries cryptées.
Oui.
Ça, c'est sûr. On travaille beaucoup avec ça pour éviter, mais je sais que c'est pas possible d'éviter toutes les intromissions dans notre système professionnel.
Bon alors, l'autre question que j'ai, c'est que je n'ai plus de possible, je peux plus aller aux États-Unis. J'ai essayé d'avoir un ESTA il y a quelques mois, mais j'ai pas pu.
Donc voilà, je peux plus aller aux États-Unis pour l'instant.
D'accord. OK. Donc à ce moment-là, il y a vraiment un effet très concret qui est—
Ouais, ouais, ouais.
Oui.
Et puis, il y a le scandale Assange. Vous vous souvenez qu'il était observé, qu'il était filmé dans l'ambassade, y compris toutes ses relations avec ses avocats.
Donc, ça veut dire que toutes nos discussions, qu'on avait de manière, pensait-on, confidentielle à l'ambassade, ont été enregistrées et ont été envoyées directement à la société de sécurité qui était en Espagne.
Et la société de sécurité l'envoyait directement aux États-Unis, à la CIA.
D'accord, ouais.
Donc, il y avait un lien direct, la CIA surveillait. Génial hein.
Comment est-ce que vous vivez ce genre de truc-là ? C'est—
Après—
Est-ce que c'est flippant ? Est-ce que c'est—
Ah c'est très—
Est-ce que vous en riez au final ou est-ce que—
Moi, ce que je me dis, c'est que finalement, comme tout est découvert à un moment donné, puisque nous, on a découvert ça, ça montre jusqu'où les États-Unis sont prêts à aller pour Assange.
Ça montre que finalement, tout ce qu'on dit, tout ce qu'on sent, en fait, on sent tous, chacun d'entre nous, que si Assange est envoyé aux États-Unis, il va y être pas bien traité du tout.
Il va pas avoir de bons procès. On va lui faire des accusations qui vont s'accumuler. Il va surtout être mis en high max, c'est-à-dire en prison de haute sécurité, dans l'isolement sensoriel.
Donc, tout le monde sait que ça va mal se passer. Mais ce qui est particulièrement complexe, c'est qu'il faut donner un habillage juridique à ça.
Et donc, par exemple, lorsqu'on s'est rendu compte qu'ils avaient violé comme ça les droits à la confidentialité entre l'avocat et son client en créant une
transmission directe des conversations qu'on avait à la CIA,
ça montre jusqu'où ils sont prêts à aller.
Mmh.
Et ça montre la disproportion, finalement. Parce qu'on parle de quelqu'un qui diffuse des informations. On parle d'un journaliste.
Il a le statut de journaliste puisqu'il est journaliste en Australie, et un publisher, donc quelqu'un qui publie des informations.
Donc c'est invraisemblable jusqu'où ils sont prêts à aller pour mettre cet Assange en prison.
Donc finalement, ça valide votre cause. Vous vous sentez légitimé, vous vous sentez validé dans votre combat.
Oui.
Mais à un niveau personnel, est-ce que vous ne flippez pas ? Est-ce que vous n'avez pas peur ? Est-ce que vous vous sentez pas en insécurité quand—
Non, jamais.
Non ?
Moi, je me sens libre en Belgique. La Belgique est un pays qui attache beaucoup d'importance à la liberté de ses avocats et qui protège ses avocats.
Et donc, moi, je me sens tout à fait à l'aise et protégé en Belgique. Et que ce soit par l'État ou la police belge ou que ce soit par
l'ordre des avocats du Barreau de Bruxelles a toujours été très soutenant dans toutes les actions qu'on a faites et, dès qu'on a un problème, la porte est ouverte pour aller chercher protection auprès du Barreau.
Dans les mois et les années qui viennent, il y a deux grands combats qui arrivent. Dans les mois qui viennent, il y a d'abord, on l'évoquait, cette notion d'extradition vers les États-Unis.
Oui.
Et puis, le cas échéant, si ça ne fonctionne pas pour vous, si l'extradition est validée, il y aura à ce moment-là le grand procès aux États-Unis. Est-ce que ce sera—
Non, mais il va pas aux États-Unis, hein. Moi, je peux pas imaginer ça une seconde, hein. Pour moi, je peux pas imaginer ça une seconde.
Bah, c'est la demande des États-Unis en tout cas.
Ouais, on est dans un pro— oui, c'est ça. Ils demandent, ils peuvent toujours demander ce qu'ils veulent, mais on est dans un processus judiciaire.
Mmh.
Et à l'université, on a toujours appris que le système judiciaire anglais était vraiment le système, le modèle quoi.
Habeas corpus, par exemple, les normes pour libérer des gens, ça vient de l'Angleterre. Donc, le système judiciaire anglais est très indépendant et très multiple.
Donc là, on est pour l'instant à Westminster Court. C'est le premier tribunal qui est à Westminster, comme son nom l'indique.
Et puis après, on va aller à la cour d'appel, si jamais. Et puis après, il y a encore possibilité d'aller, je crois que c'est la Cour suprême.
Mmh-mmh.
Et puis, qui est, je crois, la Chambre des lords, c'est l'équivalent. Et puis, si jamais tout ça rate, on peut encore aller à la Cour européenne des droits de l'homme.
Donc, on a un—
Tant qu'ils sont dans l'Union européenne ou bien même—
Non, c'est la Cour européenne, c'est le Conseil de l'Europe, donc c'est une autre enceinte juridique. Et
l'Union européenne, elle a comme Cour Luxembourg, mais le Conseil de l'Europe, qui est beaucoup plus large, qui englobe la Russie, hein, c'est l'Europe de l'Atlantique à l'Oural, comme disait de Gaulle.
OK.
C'est vraiment beaucoup plus large. Et la Cour européenne des droits de l'homme, alors, qui est la Cour européenne de cet ensemble d'États, siège à Strasbourg.
Et là, le Royaume-Uni est toujours membre du Conseil de l'Europe.
OK, OK.
Mais c'est vrai qu'il y a aussi des personnes au Royaume-Uni qui veulent sortir du Conseil de l'Europe, mais enfin, vu les difficultés, déjà, à sortir du Conseil—
Est-ce qu'ils y arriveront avant les Américains ?
C'est un scandale absolument assez— oui, c'est tellement difficile que bon, ça m'étonnerait qu'ils se lancent dans une autre aventure de si près prochainement.
Et donc, vous estimez que, genre, si ça devait arriver, ça n'arriverait pas avant des années et des années de tergiversations judiciaires ?
Normalement, oui. Enfin, on se rappelle le projet Pinochet, par exemple, qui était aussi un procès d'extradition en Grande-Bretagne.
Ça a duré plusieurs années. Donc, on pense que ça va durer plusieurs années. Mais c'est un dossier un peu exceptionnel, donc peut-être que ça va aller très vite.
On craint que ça aille plus vite que d'habitude parce qu'on craint qu'en effet, le Royaume-Uni, y compris ses juges, voudront se débarrasser au plus vite d'Assange.
Moi, je reste très confiant dans le système judiciaire parce que voilà, je pense que le dossier est tellement évident, qu'il va avoir une atteinte à sa vie.
Peut-être qu'il va être assassiné. Il y a tellement de gens qui le détestent. Il y a eu beaucoup d'appels au meurtre.
Oui, je crois que Hillary Clinton, enfin il—
Hillary Clinton avait dit qu'il fallait lui envoyer un drone.
Voilà, exact. C'est ce que j'allais dire.
C'est rien.
Je ne sais pas si c'est une vraie déclaration, mais ça me paraît assez crédible.
C'est une vraie déclaration. Elle l'a dit. Et donc ça, c'est quand même un personnage très important de l'État américain qui le dit
et donc, qui est normalement un personnage démocrate, donc qui est pas quelqu'un des blancs suprématistes quoi.
Extrêmes, ouais, ouais, c'est ça.
Mais ça, puis il va être torturé là-bas. Il est déjà torturé maintenant. Il va être détenu dans des conditions incroyables.
Quand vous dites : « Il est déjà torturé maintenant », vous parlez de conditions de détention.
Ses conditions de détention sont terrifiantes. Il fallait dire, comme je disais, vingt-trois heures sur vingt-quatre dans un lieu, après six ans d'ambassade.
L'ambassade, c'était un petit lieu confiné, un rez-de-chaussée à Londres sans lumière. Donc c'était vraiment un truc, c'était à côté du Harrods, là.
C'était bien quand on allait, on pouvait aller faire des courses. Mais c'était un petit truc, mais vraiment de rien du tout, où il avait aucun accès à l'air pur et aucun accès à la lumière directe.
Donc pendant six ans. Donc c'est pour ça que vous voyez sa photo quand il-- 'fin, ses images, quand il sort de l'ambassade, il est blanc comme un linge parce qu'il n'a plus eu un rayon de soleil sur le visage depuis six ans.
Il est devenu là-dedans très faible au niveau de sa santé physique, mais aussi sa santé mentale.
Donc, vous disiez quand vous l'aviez rencontré et que vous, vous étiez donc surveillé indirectement par les Américains-
Oui.
C'était alors dans une salle super sombre...
Non, c'était une salle de réunion de trois mètres sur trois mètres, on va dire.
Ok.
Il y a des fenêtres, mais y a pas le soleil qui rentre. C'était des fenêtres avec des rideaux.
C'est ça.
Les fenêtres sont fermées. On sait-- On sait pas ouvrir les fenêtres.
Ouais.
Donc c'était confiné. C'était un confinement, on va dire-
C'est ça.
Dans cette ambassade qui faisait peut-être cent, cent mètres carrés maximum.
Donc ça, c'était la décision à ce moment-là de l'État...
Britannique, ils ont pas beaucoup de sous. Donc ils avaient une petite ambassade au cœur de Londres.
Vraiment, c'est juste ça. C'est juste une question de budget.
Vous voyez les prix là, c'était toutes les voitures, c'était des Bentley, des Lotus...
L'état de santé de Julian Assange dépend directement de la crise immobilière de...
Mais il aurait peut-être dû aller dans l'ambassade du Brésil. Peut-être qu'il aurait eu, à l'époque de Lula, il aurait peut-être eu un meilleur traitement.
Mais là, l'ambassade était vraiment-
Pour en revenir à des points très concrets, le-- Vous le disiez il y a un instant, a priori, plutôt une confiance en l'État américain, État de droit, État, voilà, qui se bat pour les droits de l'homme, etc.
L'accusation qui est retenue contre lui, c'est principalement la notion d'acte terroriste, voilà, l'hostilité, contre, voilà, qui n'est pas très solide d'après de nombreux juristes.
Et puis en plus toute la notion, voilà, du premier amendement qui est très très protégé aux États-Unis, etc.
Moi, je trouve qu'une fois qu'il met les pieds là-bas, il est foutu en fait. Tout le monde sait ça, tout le monde sent ça.
C'est ça que je, voilà. Tout le monde le sent, mais on a confiance, mais en même temps, on n'a pas confiance.
En même temps, on se dit : Non, ils lui en veulent tellement, mais tout le monde lui en veut en plus. Quand je dis qu'il est controversé, c'est pas simplement nous par rapport
à ce qu'il a mis sur WikiLeaks, mais quand on voit les câbles démocratiques, les CND Cables, comme on dit, c'est-à-dire les révélations sur la campagne politique d'Hillary Clinton.
Quand il a fait ça, il s'est mis à dos tous les démocrates.
C'est sûr.
Parce qu'ils ont considéré après que ce qu'il avait fait avait eu pour conséquence que Trump avait été élu. Ce qui ne serait pas juste, on le saura jamais.
Mais en tout cas, je pense que le,
les électeurs américains, ils ont pas voté pour Trump parce qu'Assange a révélé que, comment dire, Hillary Clinton était soutenue par l'appareil du Parti démocratique.
C'est ça qu'il révélait. Il révélait finalement la connivence de l'appareil du Parti démocratique pour exclure Bernie Sanders.
C'était ça la révélation. C'était pas autre chose.
Il y avait par exemple des choses comme les questions au débat qui étaient envoyées à Hillary Clinton, mais pas à Bernie Sanders. Tout était préparé.
C'est pas ça qui a fait gagner Trump les élections. C'est que les Américains ont voulu Trump. Je pense qu'ils l'ont voulu, ils l'ont eu.
Voilà. Alors toutes les-- Avec le défaillant système américain.
Tout ça, le vote, le vote populaire, etc.
Oui, voilà, c'est un truc de dingue. On voit que je sais pas combien Clinton a eu, je sais pas combien de millions de votes de plus que Trump.
Malgré tout, c'est l'autre qui est élu. C'est vraiment bizarre. Ça, c'est le système américain. Je pense que ça reste quand même une très grande et très forte démocratie.
Ce qui m'intéresse ici, c'est cette notion entre d'une part, voilà, la foi, le système judiciaire, le droit avec un D majuscule, etc.
L'institution, etc. Et d'autre part, cette idée de : Oui, mais on a quand même vachement peur, en fait. Il met les pieds aux États-Unis, il a une balle dans le crâne une seconde après.
Donc cette idée de finalement, l'État de droit, ça vaut ce que ça vaut. En attendant, on n'a pas une méga confiance, on ne va pas risquer.
Donc c-- Mais par contre, vous dites en Europe, au Royaume-Uni, là, on est safe.
Je pense que la situation est un peu paradoxale. Parce que oui, on dit en Europe, il est safe, mais enfin, c'est pour ça qu'ils le gardent à Belmarsh.
C'est dans cette prison horrible et de super, super sécurité, parce qu'ils disent qu'il y a un risque pour sa vie. C'est pour le protéger lui-même qu'ils le torturent, en fait.
C'est vraiment génial comme argument. Mais moi, je pense que c'est vraiment une question européenne, en fait. C'est
pour l'instant, je pense que les États-Unis ont beaucoup baissé dans mon estime par rapport à, je pense, depuis le 11 septembre, cette période-là,
où on a vu une espèce d'attaque systématique aux droits fondamentaux…
Une tendance sécuritaire, oui.
Voilà, une tendance hyper sécuritaire par rapport à-- Et cibler des populations, ici, ce sont souvent des populations arabo-musulmanes ou d'origine arabo-musulmane.
Et donc les États-Unis se sont engouffrés là-dedans, ont fait des choses extra-extraordinairement horribles.
Et je parle par exemple ici de Guantanamo, c'est-à-dire d'avaliser la torture, de dire que la torture, on pouvait torturer des gens, hein, à condition qu'ils étaient de cette catégorie-là de personnes terroristes.
Et faire ça, c'est vraiment une attaque fondamentale à un acquis humain qui est de tout temps. De tout temps. Voilà.
C'est vraiment à partir du moment où il y a un peu d'humanité, ben, on ne torture plus. Donc c'est vraiment une régression.
On retourne avant la Révolution française, on retourne vraiment à deux cents ans en arrière, même plus que ça, deux cent cinquante ans en arrière.
C'est horrible. Ils ont fait ça, ils ont assumé ça. Et ça a créé pour moi, c'est ça qui a créé l'islamisme radical qu'il a abreuvé.
Ils ont abreuvé, ils ont créé des tigres, ils ont abreuvé avec du sang l'islamisme radical pour en arriver à la situation en Syrie.
Et c'est une erreur politique énorme qui a eu des répercussions jusqu'ici, les attentats à Bruxelles, à Zaventem, la montée de l'État islamique en Syrie.
Tout ça est lié, je pense, à la manière dont les États-Unis ont géré la crise du 11 septembre en, finalement, légitimant, parce c'est ça qu'ils ont fait.
Hein, quand on voit la propagande de l'État islamique, vous vous souvenez, c'était des gens qui étaient en orange suit comme les gens à Guantanamo et qu'on décapitait.
C'était ça. C'était dans le-- La symbolique, c'était de dire : On fait comme les Américains, on leur fait payer parce qu'ils nous ont fait ça.
Et donc je pense qu'il y a eu des erreurs politiques très importantes, que le système intérieur aux États-Unis, le système judiciaire résiste, a résisté, continue à résister de plus en plus.
Il y a toujours la notion des FISA courts, je pense. Donc c'est, c'est courts, c'est des cours de justice de, voilà, de sécurité intérieure-
Ah oui.
...où les greffes sont classées confidentielles, où on n'a pas accès aux informations, à ce qui prend place là-bas.
C'est ça, ouais, qui sont à huis clos quoi.
Voilà, c'est ça, oui. Donc, par exemple, tout ce qui concerne Snowden, etc. C'est hyper secret, hyper, voilà-
Oui, c'est ça. Il y a pas de transparence.
Voilà, mais donc, donc vous dites une résistance, voilà, une résistance du système dans l'appareil judiciaire.
Sont limitées, sont inefficaces pour l'instant.
Oui.
Elles existent, mais elles sont malheureusement un peu inefficaces. C'est l'exception en fait.
Mais c'est ça qu'il faut démontrer alors, parce que comme il y a cette confiance mutuelle, nous en tant que juristes, notre méthode, c'est dire : OK, il y a la confiance mutuelle avec les États-Unis,
on va vous démontrer que cette confiance mutuelle n'existe pas dans le cas particulier de Julian Assange,
c'est-à-dire qui est un whistleblower ou un publisher de whistleblower qui a révélé des secrets d'État des États-Unis d'Amérique.
C'est ça, c'est eux, c'est ces personnes-là qui font l'objet de violations systématiques de leurs droits fondamentaux. Ce sont les-- comme Snowden
ou Assange, lanceurs d'alertes et leurs publishers qui ont révélé des informations qui touchent vraiment au cœur
de la sûreté de l'État américain.
Parce que c'est celui-là dont on parle. On parle pas de l'État belge, on parle de l'État américain. Et ceux-là,
l'État américain ne va jamais leur pardonner, va les poursuivre jusqu'à la fin, va les torturer pour que tout le monde sache que ceux qui révèlent des informations, eh bien, ils seront traités de la sorte.
OK. Mais donc là, on commence un petit peu à tourner en rond en ce qui concerne, voilà, l'affaire de Julian Assange.
On a bien saisi la complexité du dossier.
Il y a encore plein de choses à dire.
Oui, oui.
C'est gigantesque comme affaire. C'est vraiment-- ça concerne tellement d'États. Par exemple, juste pour vous dire encore un truc-
Oui, allez-y.
...pourquoi ils sont venus l'arrêter dans l'ambassade. Le gars, il est là depuis six ans. C'est Julian Assange, le fondateur de WikiLeaks.
Il a tout son matériel personnel, c'est-à-dire qu'il a des dizaines d'ordinateurs, vous imaginez bien, des disques durs, plein de trucs, plein d'informations.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait avec ça ?
Mmm-hmm.
Ils ont pris, les Équatoriens, cette information, tout ça, tout ce qui a été saisi, et l'ont remis au procureur américain.
Et finalement, la démarche que vous avez aujourd'hui-
En échange d'un contrat du FMI de je ne sais pas combien de milliards de dollars qui vient d'être versé à l'État équatorien.
Est-ce que-
Pour des choses simples.
Est-ce que là, vous ne versez pas un tout petit peu dans le complotisme ? Est-ce que c'est certain ?
Oui, non, j'aimerais bien. J'aimerais bien, mais c'est même pas le cas. Parce qu'il y a toute une ligne du temps où on voit Mike Pompeo, de nouveau lui, qui va en Équateur, qui va rencontrer le nouveau président-
Le nouveau, oui, qui a pris la place de celui qui avait donné l'asile.
Voilà, qui a tout coiffé-phili, quoi. C'est vraiment Brutus, il a tué son père.
Enfin, c'est pas son père, mais il a tué-
Le traître.
Il a foutu un coup de poignard dans le dos à Correa, puisqu'il était élu grâce à Correa. Et puis après, paf, il a tout à fait retourné sa veste et s'est redirigé vers les Américains.
Et donc, il y a beaucoup d'informations publiques qu'on peut voir. Toutes ces évolutions d'informations, de relations entre le nouveau président équatorien et le régime américain.
Mais pour en revenir à votre rôle d'avocat, le travail que vous accomplissez aujourd'hui, notre entretien en cet instant présent où vous développez des propos, par exemple, pour,
voilà, pour dévoiler les grandes contradictions en termes d'État de droit aux États-Unis, par exemple.
Vous développez un propos, vous avez votre plaidoyer, vous développez vos arguments. Est-ce que ça fait partie de votre travail d'avocat, de, votre, voilà, de développer dans la sphère publique,
voilà, une, un plaidoyer, une idéologie, finalement, une petite
idéologie un petit peu forte.
Je vous présente mes arguments quoi.
C'est ça. Est-ce que ça fait partie de votre rôle d'avocat d'arguer dans la sphère publique, voilà, en ce qui concerne vos clients et de changer-
Bah écoutez, comme je vous disais-
...la perception de la sphère publique à son sujet ?
Oui, oui, mais comme je vous le disais au début, donc quand on a créé cette association d'avocats ici, Hughes Coguens,
avec, il y avait Annie Michaux, il y avait aussi Nicolas Cohen, il y avait Sonia Chiavi, enfin Dounia Alamat.
On était cinq à la base. Et on avait pour objectif aussi de créer un cabinet d'avocats qui aurait une influence sur la société.
Donc, ce n'est pas juste un cabinet d'avocats qui allait défendre des affaires. On voulait avoir une influence sur la société, sur la politique, sur la façon dont la société envisageait certaines problématiques.
Parce que je considère et nous considérons qu'il y a l'avocat et les procès, même de manière générale, ont un rôle aussi pour faire évoluer la société.
Hein, et que des bons jugements, des bonnes prises de position, que ce soit dans les juridictions internes ou au niveau international,
peuvent faire changer le législateur, peuvent l'obliger à prendre des nouvelles lois, mais peuvent aussi faire changer des mentalités.
Et donc, dans le cadre de, plus général, de ce projet politique qu'on a au sein du cabinet, c'est-à-dire d'un engagement social.
Moi, je suis très engagé au Centre d'action laïque, par exemple. J'ai été engagé avec les Droits de l'Homme. Il y a certains cabinets qui sont engagés dans l'Observatoire international des prisons.
On a-- C'est aussi un élément important au cabinet, c'est d'avoir des avocats dans la société.
Pas des avocats en dehors de la société, mais qu'on fait partie de la société et on s'investit dans cette société pour essayer d'avoir un changement social progressiste.
C'est ça notre objectif, hein, pour que nos enfants aient un meilleur avenir, quand même meilleur présent que le nôtre. Hein, pour dire les choses simplement, mais un peu naïvement.
Mais dans ce cadre-là, alors, ça nous arrive, oui, d'avoir des actions au niveau médiatique pour faire passer les idées qu'on peut avoir.
Ça, c'est une chose. L'autre chose, c'est qu'en effet, dans les stratégies de défense, on a des stratégies de PR, de public relationship.
Mmm-hmm.
Public relation. On a-
Qui font à ce moment-là explicitement partie de votre contrat, c'est vrai ?
Oui, c'est dans le contrat. C'est-à-dire qu'à un moment donné, on se rend compte que dans tel dossier, ben, le dossier va avoir des influences médiatiques.
Et donc ça veut dire qu'on va prendre des positions médiatiques, on va donner nos points de vue au niveau médiatique pour essayer d'avoir une influence sur l'opinion publique, pour l'informer aussi-
Mmm.
...de la situation, puisqu'on est-- en tant qu'avocat, on est vraiment à la source de beaucoup d'informations. Donc, on a des informations de première main.
Donc, on va donner ces informations au grand public pour que notre thèse, évidemment, on va pas faire ça pour soutenir l'adversaire, mais pour que notre thèse
soit plus-- favorablement accueillie dans l'opinion publique.
Parfois, c'est difficile. Parfois, on a des dossiers, ici, mon ami Nicolas Coy, il défend par exemple les mères djihadistes, les enfants djihadistes, pour les faire revenir.
C'est difficile. On est ma-- souvent-
Oui. C'est un peu le diagnostic intellectuel pour arriver à-
On reçoit des lettres de menace. Enfin bon, on sait pas, mais on tient sur nos deux jambes, on veut dire, parce qu'on défend vraiment des valeurs auxquelles on croit.
Et donc, dans ce cadre-là, on est appelé à, en effet, à les communiquer par la presse. Mais y a aussi, comme vous dites, parfois, des, même des stratégies que je ne vous révèlerai pas, mais très complexes de communication.
Encore deux questions sur l'affaire Assange et puis on enchaînera sur d'autres affaires.
Je vais dire l'affaire Assange, hein.
Oui, mais c'est celle qui occupe le plus l'actualité.
C'est une affaire passionnante.
En plus de l'espace qu'elle occupe dans l'actualité, c'est une affaire qui, voilà, comme vous le dites, a une certaine nuance, une certaine, voilà-
Oui.
Y a un de-
Et puis c'est fondamental au 21e siècle par rapport à la question de la révolution Internet. C'est ça qui est aus-
Que vous avez bien développé, oui. Mais donc ce qui est intéressant, c'est pourquoi est-ce que l'image de Julian Assange est aussi,
voilà, c'est aussi démoniaque, celle d'un démon, celle de, voilà, une personne, un personnage controversé.
Vous dites : « En grande partie, en très grande partie, c'est, ce sont des constructions, c'était une campagne de démonisation. »
Diabolisation.
Démonisation, c'est de l'anglais, à mon avis.
Ah oui, peut-être.
Oui, oui, oui.
Mais ce ne sera pas la première fois que je vais faire un anglicisme.
Aux yeux du grand public, finalement, les auditeurs et les auditrices qui nous écoutent aujourd'hui, quel conseil, enfin, quelle est votre perspective par rapport à l'information, le droit à l'information du citoyen ?
Est-ce qu'aujourd'hui,
on est correctement informé par rapport à ces questions-là ? Ou bien est-ce que vous estimez qu'il y a un travail à faire
pour chacun et chacune des personnes qui nous écoutent aujourd'hui pour mieux s'informer, pour mieux comprendre ces choses-là ?
Donc, vous voyez ce que je veux dire. Y a une espèce de contradiction entre l'information qu'on reçoit et qui, d'après ce que vous dites, a besoin d'être discréditée, a besoin d'être remise en question.
Oui, oui.
Quel conseil alors à ce moment-là pour les auditeurs qui nous écoutent ?
Un petit Google, c'est facile, hein.
Oui, c'est ça. Mais donc, mais ça, ça n'est pas une information qui nous arrive de manière passive par les médias traditionnels.
Ben, je crois que si, quand même. Y a quand même beaucoup de jouets. Je-
C'est vrai que parfois, on se plaint de la couverture médiatique de l'affaire Assange, mais je pense qu'il y a une évolution importante qui se fait et que petit à petit,
l'information pertinente et importante arrive dans les médias.
OK. Donc, vous êtes satisfait à ce niveau-là ?
Pas satisfait, parce qu'il faut que vous en ayez plus, mais ça va. Je trouve qu'il y a-
Alors, dernière question pour en venir à la nature du contrat qui vous unit avec Julian Assange. Julian Assange ne travaille pas, il est coincé dans un centre de sécurité.
La question est plutôt simple. Finalement, comment est-ce que vous êtes rémunéré ? Qui paye pour la défense de Julian Assange ?
Moi, j'ai pas de difficulté à parler de ça. Donc au départ, il nous a engagés parce qu'il cherchait un cabinet européen spécialisé en droits de l'homme au niveau européen.
Et donc via son avocat américain qui s'appelait Michael Ratner, qui gérait la défense à l'époque, qui est un avocat qui vivait à New York, qui avait créé un gros cabinet d'avocats là-bas.
Michael Ratner nous a contactés en disant : « Voilà, vous êtes les meilleurs en Europe pour faire ça. » Ça fait toujours plaisir qu'on nous dise ça, mais voilà.
Et donc c'est comme ça qu'Assange nous a contactés, parce qu'il voulait avoir le meilleur avocat européen en droits humains.
Et donc il a frappé à notre porte. On était très fiers de ça, évidemment.
Et puis donc, pendant tout un temps, on a dit OK, on a travaillé, on a fait beaucoup de recherches, on a fait du, ce qu'on appelle du litigation support, c'est-à-dire qu'on a fait un soutien
de contentieux au contentieux suédois.
Donc, on a porté des arguments de droits humains, de droits de l'Union européenne, de droits de la Cour, la Convention européenne des droits de l'homme.
Et donc là, on a été payés pour faire ce travail-là. Ça a duré pendant deux ans, je crois. On a été payés 12 000 euros.
Mh. OK.
On était à cinq, six. C'était pas super bien payé parce que quand on voit toutes les heures qu'on a passées, c'était...
Mais pour nous, c'était très important, intéressant. Puis quand ce contrat-là s'est terminé, donc le litigation support pour la Suède, on est restés dans l'équipe.
Et là, on est restés un peu, où finalement, on avait des défraiements quoi. C'est-à-dire que les voyages qu'on faisait, ben, ils étaient remboursés, quand on allait à Londres, tout ça.
Mais on n'avait plus de paiement vraiment sur le fond du travail. Et maintenant, nous avons décidé de passer en pro bono, c'est-à-dire de ne pas être payés.
Donc, on se rend bien compte que Julian Assange, pour l'instant, c'est difficile pour lui de gérer six équipes de défense.
Hein. Il y en a une en Équateur, une aux États-Unis, en Australie, en Suède, en Europe, en Espagne, en Grande-Bretagne.
En Europe, c'est-- Ben justement, j'allais dire en Europe, c'est vous, c'est Eusko Gaz qui-- Vous gérez l'entièreté de l'Union européenne, ouais.
Et donc ça fait, c'est énorme. Et donc il a pas la capacité de faire ça. Donc ça veut dire que nous, on lui a dit : « Ben voilà, écoute Julian, maintenant, on va travailler gratuitement pour toi,
à partir de maintenant, en pro bono comme on dit.
Et puis si jamais on gagne un jour à la Cour européenne des droits de l'homme ou je sais pas ailleurs, si on gagne des dommages et intérêts, ben on se paiera éventuellement sur la bête.
» Mais c'est même pas ça la question.
Nous, on travaille pro bono parce que, pour nous, ça nous semble des questions qui sont fondamentales, qui sont vraiment, qui touchent vraiment au cœur notre métier d'avocat
et que, entre nous, ça fait partie aussi de l'esprit qu'on veut,
donner au cabinet et on se ratable dans d'autres dossiers où on n'est pas pro bono, où on est payés, je dirais, comme les avocats sont payés,
dans des dossiers importants au niveau international.
Comme ça, voilà, on contextualise bien la nature de vos rapports avec Julian Assange.
Vous préfériez que je sois avec Snowden.
Mais donc justement, on a pu développer donc le dossier de Edward Snowden. On a pu développer la question de, enfin, le dossier de Julian Assange et de WikiLeaks.
Troisième nom que j'avais pu citer en début de podcast, c'était Carles Puigdemont.
Oui.
Qui donc réside toujours, je crois, à Waterloo, quelques kilomètres au sud-
Avenue de l'Avocat, oui. Ça ne s'invente pas.
C'est ça. Quel, voilà, je vous ai évoqué en début de podcast vos grandes convictions en ce qui concerne le droit à la dissidence.
Mmh.
Qu'est-ce qui vous a amené à croiser le chemin de Carles Puigdemont ?
Ben,
je crois que le premier point, c'est que comme on a développé cette expertise en droits humains en Belgique, etc., et puis qu'on est spécialisé aussi en extradition, c'est un peu ça notre, vraiment notre niche, on va dire,
au niveau même mondial, on va dire.
Moi, j'ai des clients qui sont par exemple au Mexique et qui me consultent, ou des clients qui sont en Inde. Enfin, je dirais, j'ai-- aux États-Unis, donc c'est assez vaste comme contentieux.
Mais donc ça veut dire que voilà, comme on est spécialisé dans l'extradition, il s'agit d'une affaire d'extradition, donc c'est normal qu'ils viennent chez nous, puisqu'on a cette spécialité au niveau belge.
Ça, c'est une chose. L'autre chose, c'est que nous, c'est un dossier qui nous a très vite passionnés. Qui nous a très vite passionnés parce que
l'affaire catalane est une affaire qui, pour moi, est une affaire centrale, en Europe au XXIe siècle.
On sent tous qu'il y a un truc qui se joue là. On sait pas très bien quoi,
mais y a quelque chose qui se joue là et que, on sent aussi que les poursuites pénales qui sont exercées pour régler un problème politique sont disproportionnées et que ça vise de nouveau à réprimer la dissidence,
sans mesure, sans proportion, et que,
ça se passe au cœur de l'Union européenne.
Quand je dis le cœur de l'Union européenne, je considère que l'Espagne, c'est pas un pays fondateur de l'Union européenne, mais je considère que c'est comme si c'était un pays fondateur.
C'est vraiment un pilier de l'Union européenne. Et que ça se passe au cœur de l'Union européenne,
cette répression disproportionnée, cette atteinte à des droits fondamentaux des personnes poursuivies constantes, est vraiment pour moi inacceptable.
Et y a quelque chose qui se joue, qui est bizarre parce qu'il y a en même temps le silence de l'Europe, hein, l'Union européenne ne fait rien.
Sauf Théo Francken qui se prononçait.
Oui, c'est ça. Et c'est vraiment quelque chose qui est choquant. Mais je pense pas que ça va durer non plus.
Moi, je suis un grand optimiste, vous avez compris.
Oui, oui.
Mais je pense que petit à petit, on va se rendre compte que Théo Francken a raison, qu'il y a un vrai problème en Catalogne et qu'il faut que l'État de droit, il soit respecté complètement.
Quand on entend Théo Francken, on a immédiatement tendance à dire qu'il y a un intérêt politique à, voilà, cette notion de séparatisme qui lui parle, qui parle très fort à sa fibre.
Oui, lui, ça le fait kiffer, on va dire. Simplement, il adore ça. Même si les séparatistes catalans sont plutôt à gauche, hein, donc ils sont pas spécialement dans leur...
Mais ça, ils s'en foutent.
Ouais, c'est clair.
Ils les adorent, c'est leur héros, quoi. Ils ont déclaré l'indépendance de la Catalogne. Ça, c'est un truc, leur rêve le plus fou s'est réalisé, quoi, en Catalogne.
Donc, ils les adorent, ils les soutiennent, tant mieux, hein, parce que,
je veux dire, qu'ils habillent leur amour de l'indépendance et du séparatisme de la défense des droits fondamentaux des Catalans, tant mieux, hein, tant mieux pour les Catalans, on va dire.
Mais c'est un sujet passionnant. C'est un sujet difficile et je m'en, je, comment dire ?
Souvent, j'ai des discussions virulentes avec mes amis, parce que mes amis ne sont pas d'accord avec moi-
D'accord
...sur la chose suivante. C'est que moi, je considère qu'il y a un débat démocratique en Catalogne et en Espagne qui est très impressionnant et très intéressant.
Et que quand je vois un million et demi ou deux millions de personnes dans la rue, hein, sur une population, je sais pas combien ils sont, huit, dix millions, un peu comme tous les Belges, c'est vraiment impressionnant.
Parce qu'on dit toujours que pour l'instant, en Europe, il y a une espèce de dédain pour la politique, que les gens ne sont plus intéressés par la politique.
Sept millions et demi de personnes vivent en Catalogne.
Sept millions et demi, voilà. Il y en a deux millions qui descendent dans la rue. Mais donc, on dit toujours qu'il y a un dédain pour la politique.
Là, pas du tout. On voit deux millions de personnes dans la rue, hein, avec des familles entières, avec des, tout que-- intergénérationnel.
C'est ça qui est super impressionnant. C'est que chaque fois, il y a à la fois les grands-pères, les mères, les enfants, les ados.
Même les ados qui sont un peu en révolte, ils sont aussi indépendantistes. Hein, les garçons et les filles
rebelles là-bas, ils vont pas au PTB, ici, comme ici en Belgique ou aux Jeunes Communistes ou aux Jeunes je sais pas quoi.
Ils sont indépendantistes. C'est dingue. C'est un truc vraiment impressionnant.
À titre personnel, j'ai eu l'occasion de croiser la route d'une personne qui venait de Catalogne.
Oui.
Et effectivement, c'était très drôle comment on lui demandait en début de conversation si elle était espagnole et elle répondait oui parce qu'elle était à l'étranger et qu'elle se sentait un petit peu obligée.
Mais en développant la conversation, on fait : « Mais tu vis en Catalogne, mais tu dis que tu es espagnole. » Elle fait : « Oui, non, je fais semblant.
En vrai, je me sens absolument pas espagnole. »
Et un peu plus tard, j'avais une conversation avec une Espagnole à ce sujet et cette personne espagnole, elle n'accordait aucun crédit à ce que, aux convictions de la personne de Catalogne.
Oui, c'est une grande incompréhension. Il y a un mur de non-communication qui est gigantesque. C'est ce mur-là qu'il faut,
qu'il faut casser plutôt que mettre les gens en prison et amener des milliers et des milliers de policiers, parce que c'est ça qui s'est passé.
Alors moi, je crois que le fond de l'affaire, c'est qu'à un moment donné, Rajoy, le président chrétien-démocrate, qui n'avait pas de majorité, hein,
a saisi l'opportunité de ce référendum pour essayer de faire un écran de fumée en envoyant les policiers parce qu'il était concerné par plein d'affaires, en espérant que ça allait le sauver.
Mmh.
Ça l'a pas sauvé. Il est tombé, rappelons-nous, pour des affaires, hein, parce qu'il y avait des détournements gigantesques.
C'est pour ça qu'il est tombé, Rajoy. Je veux dire, l'Espagne est un pays dans lequel il y a eu énormément de malversations au niveau politique et où la confiance dans la politique est encore beaucoup plus, je dirais, atteinte que chez nous.
Hein, c'est peut-être 10, 15 fois plus de personnes inculpées pour des faits de corruption en Espagne que chez nous.
Et donc ce contexte-là a permis l'émergence de ce mouvement, je, de démocratique, un mouvement démocratique indépendantiste.
C'est comme ça que je l'appelle. Ce n'est pas un mouvement nationaliste. J'aime pas mes copains, mes copines qui me disent : « Oui, mais tu défends les nationalistes.
» Les nationalistes, ce sont des gens qui sont des créateurs de guerre. C'est différent. En Catalogne, c'est pas comme ça.
Y a un véritable mouvement démocratique fort,
avec une aspiration à une amélioration de la vie ensemble, parce que c'est ça qui est très important, intergénérationnelle, qui est vraiment puissante.
Donc c'est intéressant au niveau démocratique. Et puis après, les poursuites, par contre, telles qu'elles sont exercées, là, on est dans la disproportion complète.
C'est un calvaire pour ceux qui y vivent, hein.
Pour remettre un petit peu les choses en contexte, quels sont les accusations, les chefs d'accusation qui sont retenus contre Carles Puigdemont aujourd'hui ? Qu'est-ce que-
Aujourd'hui, on retient l'accusation de sédition et de malversation.
Alors expliquez-nous.
Voilà, autrefois, c'était rébellion, rebelión en espagnol et sédition en espagnol. Ce sont des vieilles infractions pénales.
Rebelión, c'est la révolution. Donc c'est aux armes, aux armes citoyens. Ce sont des gens qui demandent au peuple de prendre les armes et d'aller attaquer les institutions.
C'est la définition pénale. Ils n'ont jamais fait ça. Ils ont organisé un, enfin je veux dire, un référendum. C'est juste ça qu'ils ont fait.
Comment ils ont fait ce référendum le 1er octobre 2017. Il y a d'abord une campagne électorale où ils ont fait une coalition Junts per Sí, c'est-à-dire Ensemble pour le Oui, où ils ont
gagné les élections avec comme thème de campagne, on va organiser un référendum d'autodétermination.
Ils ont gagné les élections et puis ils ont fait ce qu'ils ont dit, c'est-à-dire, ils ont pris des lois, des arrêtés pour organiser le référendum.
Donc les élections officielles dans un premier temps et puis un référendum qui-
Inconstitutionnel
Pour certains n'est pas reconnu, n'est pas, oui.
C'était inconstitutionnel, c'était un référendum qui n'avait aucune valeur, aucune valeur. Et puis, entre nous, pour moi, la question démocratique, c'est,
est la suivante : comment est-ce qu'on fait un changement institutionnel majeur dans un État ?
Est-ce qu'on le fait par une majorité de cinquante virgule zéro deux pour cent comme le Brexit ou cinquante-et-un virgule...
Non. En Belgique, on a des bonnes règles, on va dire, pour nous dire qu'on est dans un chouette État. Une réforme constitutionnelle, c'est deux tiers.
C'est ça.
C'est deux tiers avec auparavant déjà dissolution du Parlement, etc. Donc c'est une procédure longue et difficile. Il faut vraiment avoir une nouvelle, je dirais,
entente, et, ce qu'on n'arrivera jamais sans doute en Espagne.
Mais peu importe, ça, c'est le,
les erreurs espagnoles, sont très simples aussi. Je sais pas si vous avez vu un peu-- ce qui est intéressant dans le dossier catalan, pour bien le comprendre, c'est de revenir chaque fois un petit peu en arrière.
Je vous ai donné le 1er octobre 2017, jour du référendum, un an avant les élections, avec la coalition pour organiser le référendum.
Et puis, quelques années avant, qu'est-ce qu'il y a eu ? Il y a eu une autonomie qui a été octroyée à la Catalogne par le gouvernement Zapatero, donc socialiste.
Et cette loi, qui octroyait une autonomie assez importante, a été tout à coup annulée par la Cour constitutionnelle,
qui fait par ailleurs l'objet de critiques très importantes du Conseil de l'Europe parce qu'elle n'est pas indépendante, elle est trop politique, parce que la droite était encore au pouvoir au sein de la Cour constitutionnelle, qui a
détruit cette indépendance.
Et à cette autonomie, entre guillemets, de la Catalogne. Et du coup, les partis indépendantistes ont tout à coup gagné énormément dans les élections.
Ils gagnaient pas avant. Pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ont commencé à gagner ? À cause de ça, à cause de cet événement-là.
Ouais, OK.
Donc il suffirait de revenir, enfin, il suffirait, maintenant, on va pas donner des solutions à Sanchez, hein, mais il faut retrouver un dialogue politique, c'est sûr.
Et donc, pour revenir aux chefs d'accusation qui sont retenus contre lui. Donc, le premier, vous disiez sédition.
Sédition, ouais.
Et malversation, ouais.
Concrètement, est-ce qu'on est dans le faux ? Est-ce qu'on est dans le vrai ? Est-ce que vous estimez que votre client doit plaider coupable ?
Est-ce que vous estimez qu'il est innocent ?
Alors, Nicolas, c'est cette saga catalane, parce que c'est vraiment une saga, c'est le troisième mandat d'arrêt européen qu'on reçoit.
Les deux premiers, on les a, ben, je dirais, écartés avec des longues argumentations.
Et ce qui-- je vous dis ça parce que ce qui est intéressant, c'est que c'est le troisième mandat d'arrêt européen, toujours pour les mêmes faits : l'organisation du référendum, le fait d'avoir voté des lois et de passer des arrêtés pour l'organiser. Hein, c'est tout.
Par exemple, pour ouvrir une parenthèse sur la malversation qui est reprochée, c'est quoi ? C'est d'avoir mis à disposition ou d'avoir utilisé des deniers de ministère pour organiser le référendum, pour payer des urnes, par exemple,
hein, avec l'argent du ministère de la Santé.
Mais ça s'est pas passé comme ça. C'est-à-dire, l'accusation de malversation est fausse. Donc toute l'organisation du référendum s'est réalisée sur base de fonds privés.
Donc c'est-à-dire que c'est le peuple catalan qui a financé l'élection. Sédition, ce qui est intéressant par rapport à ça, ça ressemble un peu à la rébellion,
c'est que vous avez déjà une décision allemande, hein, la Cour d'appel de Schleswig-Holstein, qui a pris une décision en disant que
cette infraction de sédition ou de rébellion n'existe pas en droit allemand, parce qu'il faut une violence très importante pour qu'on y arrive.
Cette infraction, elle existe dans tous les codes pénaux du monde. Elle existe dans tous les codes pénaux du monde. C'est-à-dire que, évidemment,
dans le code pénal belge, vous avez des dispositions où la rébellion armée contre la forme du gouvernement est interdite et est passible des sanctions les plus graves, parce que c'est vraiment, on va-- l'État ne va pas permettre que
quelqu'un arme les citoyens pour prendre le pouvoir.
C'est tout à fait interdit. Mais on est sur la question fondamentale de la violence. Est-ce qu'il y a eu une violence dans l'organisation du référendum, dans le vote au référendum ?
C'est ça qui est visé.
Et vous dites violence policière, alors ?
Ben, moi, après, je dis violence policière, oui, mais la question, c'est de savoir est-ce qu'il y a une violence de la part de ceux qui ont organisé ?
C'est ça.
Est-ce que Puigdemont a armé les citoyens catalans pour organiser un référendum ? La réponse est bien évidente : non. Donc y a pas d'infraction par rapport à ça.
Et donc, votre approche, c'est qu'il doit être jugé et vous allez plaider en sa faveur en Espagne ou bien est-ce qu'il doit rester très très loin de l'Espagne, il doit rester planqué à Waterloo ?
Alors, ce qui est passionnant dans ce dossier, c'est qu'on est dans l'Union européenne.
Oui.
Et que donc, ce qui se passe en Espagne a une influence sur ce qui se passe ailleurs dans l'Union européenne. Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ?
Ça veut dire que quand y a eu ces mandats d'arrêt qui, on parlait de mandat d'arrêt qui allait être émis contre le gouvernement catalan, à ce moment-là, certains d'entre eux ont décidé de choisir l'exil.
Pourquoi ? Pour une voie de l'internationalisation du conflit, comme ils ont dit. C'est-à-dire qu'il fallait présenter ces cas auxquels ils sont soumis,
à d'autres juges, à des juges de l'Union européenne, à nos cousins.
Je veux dire, on est cousins dans l'Union européenne, c'est vraiment, on est très proches.
Ici, s'il était resté, ça aurait été jugé localement, mais comme il est parti en exil-
Voilà.
Là, on passe au niveau européen.
Là, on a un œil étranger. La Belgique a jeté un œil dessus en disant : « Non, ça marche pas. On peut pas mettre ces gens en prison.
» L'Allemagne a dit : « Non, ça marche pas. » La Suisse, parce qu'en Suisse, ils ont même dit : « Ne nous présentez pas ce mandat d'arrêt, on va jamais l'exécuter.
Ils sont poursuivis pour des raisons politiques. »
Oui, la Suisse, particulièrement neutre, hein.
Oui, c'est ça. Surtout pas.
Ouais, c'est ça.
Ne nous présentez pas ce truc-là.
Ne nous parlez pas.
C'est manifestement politique, on veut pas, hein.
Ouais, c'est ça.
C'est un délit politique, on veut pas s'en charger. En Écosse, y a le procès qui est en cours aussi pour d'autres.
Mais donc c'est ça finalement le--
on va dire que c'est aussi un coup de génie parce que ça permet alors de pouvoir donner une perspective européenne à un problème qui paraît être au départ un problème purement espagnol et qui permet à des juges européens,
sur base des mêmes valeurs, puisqu'on partage tous les mêmes valeurs dans l'Union européenne.
C'est ça qui fonde l'Union européenne, c'est qu'on essaie de construire la meilleure démocratie du monde. C'est ça qu'on essaie de faire.
Et donc, pour construire la meilleure démocratie du monde, il faut qu'on ait les valeurs fondamentales les plus sûres, les plus fermes et les mêmes, qu'on les partage.
Et donc, quand le juge belge regarde son dossier que le juge espagnol lui envoie, il lui dit : Excusez-moi, collègue, mais là, je suis pas d'accord avec vous parce que vous portez atteinte aux valeurs fondamentales de l'Union européenne.
Mh. Eh bien.
Et on espère que demain, le juge espagnol dira la même chose à un juge belge s'il se perd.
Et en termes d'évolution à court terme pour ce dossier-là, où est-ce que-- c'est en cours de traitement ?
On va plaider le 16 décembre.
16 décembre. Qu'est-ce qui se passe le 16 décembre ?
On plaide devant la Chambre du conseil, donc qui est la première instance qui va évaluer si oui ou non, on peut autoriser la remise de
Carles Puigdemont et de deux de ses anciens conseillers, Toni Comín et Lluís Puig, à Madrid ou pas.
OK.
Et puis il y aura appel si on perd, on va en appel.
Ouais.
Si on gagne, peut-être que le procureur ira pas en appel parce qu'il sera dégoûté tellement on aura présenté des arguments super forts et qu'il voudra pas faire appel.
Peut-être pas, on verra.
Et je suppose qu'en fait, quand je pose la question à un avocat, est-ce que vous croyez que vous avez des chances solides ?
L'avocat va toujours me répondre : Mais oui, nous allons gagner.
Non. Il y a parfois des procès qu'on fait, mais qu'on sait qu'on va perdre.
Oui, oui, mais est-ce que vous la voulez-
Pour faire évoluer la jurisprudence ou parfois, on perd sur un point, mais on gagne sur un autre. Ici, est-ce qu'on va gagner ?
J'espère qu'on va gagner. On a beaucoup d'arguments, avec des arguments nouveaux, du style l'immunité parlementaire pour l'instant, puisqu'ils ont été élus tous les deux parlementaires européens.
Donc, je parle de Toni Comín, de Carles Puigdemont. Et donc, normalement, ils bénéficient de l'immunité et aussi de l'inviolabilité, comme on dit.
C'est-à-dire qu'à partir du moment où ils ont une fonction publique, comme député, on peut pas les arrêter. Parce que justement, c'est une vieille règle de séparation des pouvoirs que le judiciaire peut pas empêcher le parlementaire de fonctionner.
Et donc, il y a cette inviolabilité, le temps de la fonction, on peut pas toucher. Donc ça veut dire qu'on pourrait pas les arrêter pour le mandat d'arrêt européen.
On pourrait pas mettre à exécution le mandat d'arrêt européen s'il bénéficie de cette immunité ou inviolabilité. Ça dépend comment on l'appelle.
Et c'est une question qui est très controversée. Il y a déjà eu des positions du Parlement européen qui a dit : Mais non, ils n'ont pas cette immunité.
Et l'affaire a été portée à la Cour européenne à Strasbourg. Donc, il est très probable que nous, on va demander maintenant que la question soit posée à Strasbourg.
Donc, le système de l'Union européenne,
le principe de base, c'est que
tout le monde a tous le même droit. Et pour qu'on ait tous le même droit,
ça veut dire que les juges qui vont appliquer ce droit, eh bien, s'ils ont un doute par rapport à l'interprétation du droit, ils peuvent saisir une même cour qui est cette Cour de Luxembourg,
la Cour de justice de l'Union européenne.
Et donc, n'importe quel juge de l'Union européenne, quand il applique le droit de l'Union européenne, il peut saisir cette cour pour savoir qu'est-ce que ça veut dire la loi.
Et on va faire la même chose ici. On va demander aux juges belges qu'ils saisissent la Cour européenne de justice de Luxembourg pour qu'elle statue sur le fait de savoir s'ils ont oui ou non l'immunité.
Et donc, le choix des mots est important. Vous évoquiez, vous disiez il y a un instant : J'espère que nous allons gagner.
Ouais.
Vous n'êtes pas certain, vous n'avez pas une certitude-
Je n'ai pas de boule de cristal, vous l'avez dit.
Une conviction. Non, mais vous pourriez rentrer en tribunal et vous dire : C'est dans la poche, finger in the nose, c'est bon, on a gagné ou bien-- mais à ce stade, vous dites-
Ben il y a toujours une incertitude, hein.
Toujours une incertitude.
Oui, oui, on sait jamais, hein. On peut être passé à côté d'un argument ou le juge peut avoir une autre opinion.
C'est ça la liberté judiciaire.
Très bien.
Et puis on ira en appel si jamais on n'est pas satisfait.
Qui vivra verra. Le 16 décembre, alors, pour le cas de Carles Puigdemont. Donc ça, c'est pour Carles Puigdemont.
Est-ce que vous avez un mot pour clore...
Non, ben, on a, jusqu'ici, au sein du cabinet, beaucoup travaillé sur ce droit à la dissidence qui pour nous est très important, qui est au cœur de la démocratie.
C'est vraiment là où on peut reconnaître une démocratie, c'est à la manière dont elle traite les dissidents, c'est-à-dire ceux qui pensent autrement,
qui ne sont pas dans le mainstream et qui, voilà, par liberté, par choix, choisissent de penser ou de vivre autrement.
Mh.
Et ce sont ces gens-là que nous, on défendra jusqu'au bout.
On a un peu à croiser les chemins entre le droit et l'idéologie. Est-ce qu'il vous arrive de défendre des personnes avec qui vous êtes en désaccord complet idéologiquement ou bien est-ce qu'il vous faut toujours ce moteur de...
C'est une très bonne question parce que je-- ça m'arrive, en fait, pas. Je me rends compte que-
On vous sent très animé, même par des convictions, par des fondamentaux, etc. Est-ce qu'il vous arrive de jeter un dossier ?
Oui, oui, oui, ça m'arrive, mais
c'est rare, hein. Je veux dire, c'est pas... Mais c'est vrai qu'on est plus à l'aise à défendre des dossiers dans lesquels on croit que des dossiers dans lesquels on croit pas.
Le fait qu'on croit ou pas dans les dossiers, c'est évidemment très important, mais c'est sûr qu'il y a parfois des ambiguïtés parce que
parfois, quand on défend, même quand on défend des criminels, ça peut nous arriver encore, hein, parce qu'on fait beaucoup de tour appel,
ben on les défend, oui, pour essayer que ces personnes soient le mieux défendues possible, que leurs droits fondamentaux soient respectés.
Parce que c'est évidemment aussi une question clé dans l'État de droit du XXIᵉ siècle, c'est que même les droits fondamentaux des personnes qui sont détestées, des personnes qui sont des criminels, doivent être respectés.
C'est une question d'humanité. J'étais assez étonné, j'étais l'autre jour, c'était un groupe d'amis qui m'invitait,
et il y avait des, pour parler aux enfants qui ont 14, 15 ans, un peu, qui cherchent un peu des vocations quoi.
Ouais.
Et paf, il y en a deux qui me posent la question, qui me disent : Oui, la peine de mort, qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la peine de mort, et qu'est-ce que-- Et je me suis dit,
c'est vraiment la question qu'on se pose toujours, cette question de la peine de mort.
Et la réponse à cette question-là est une question philosophique.
D'accord, oui.
Pour moi. C'est une question d'humanité. C'est-à-dire que-- moi, j'étais étonné qu'ils la posent, hein.
Oui, c'est ça, parce que oui. Pour moi, ça sonne-
C'était dans un milieu assez, je dirais éduqué, etc.
Oui, c'est ça.
Ils étaient à Saint-Michel, les deux gamins, à mon avis. Et je me suis dit-
Qu'est-ce que je comprends, alors ?
Moi, j'ai moi-même été à Godinne-sur-Meuse, donc voilà, j'ai un peu d'affinité avec Saint-Michel. Mais, et je me suis dit : Waouh, ils posent la question, mais la réponse, elle doit être philosophique, elle doit être intellectuelle.
C'est-à-dire que c'est un enjeu d'humanité et que l'humanisme interdit la peine de mort.
Magnifique conclusion alors sur la peine de mort, même si je ne m'attendais pas à ce qu'on arrive sur ce sujet-là, mais c'est tout à fait intéressant et c'est tout à fait lié à ce qu'on a pu développer une heure durant.
Merci beaucoup, Christophe Marchand, pour ces-
Merci à vous. Merci à vous. Ça fait du bien d'avoir une petite respiration, un peu comme ça dans l'actualité des dossiers.
Voilà. J'espère que le plaisir est de partager. En tout cas, pour moi, c'était formidablement intéressant. Merci beaucoup.
Merci à vous.
À très bientôt. Au revoir.
Au revoir.
Voilà, j'espère que ça vous a plu. Interviewer un avocat, c'est un exercice assez différent de ce que je fais d'habitude.
J'aurais bien voulu être encore mieux préparé pour pouvoir faire encore plus de fact-checking. Mais, dans tous les cas, je pense que c'est très intéressant d'entendre le point de vue des défenseurs de Julian Assange, puisque, en général,
on entend plutôt ceux qui le critiquent.
Un point à clarifier avant de se quitter. On a appris en début de semaine que les poursuites contre Julian Assange en Suède allaient être abandonnées,
ce qui va complètement dans le sens du propos que développait Maître Marchand pendant cette interview.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner au podcast pour ne pas rater les prochains épisodes, à nous suivre sur les réseaux sociaux et surtout,
à parler du podcast autour de vous et à m'envoyer vos retours critiques, vos compliments, vos encouragements ou tout ce que vous voulez.
J'adore recevoir les messages d'auditeurs. Allez, à très bientôt. Portez-vous bien.